KATE: Good afternoon,
everyone.
Welcome to Authors at Google
New York, our special
Valentine's Day Poetry
Workshop.
What we're going to do today
is we have four fine poets
from Four Way Books who will
give readings of their current
work, and then they will provide
prompts for you to
take home a poem to someone
you love today.
Change it up a little bit
from what is expected.
So it is my great pleasure to
introduce Victoria Lynn McCoy.
She works with Four Way Books,
and has been integral in
bringing poetry to Google New
York office, and she will
introduce the first poet.
Thank you.
VICTORIA MCCOY: Thank you, Kate,
and to Google for having
us back, and thank you, all
of you, for being here.
My name is Victoria McCoy.
I'm Assistant Editor and
Publicist for Four Way Books.
We are a nonprofit literary
press based out in Tribeca.
We publish 11 to 13 books
of poetry and short
fiction each year.
And we are really excited to
have this ongoing partnership
with Google to bring
poetry to you guys.
So I'll just get started.
Our first reader is Alex
Dimitrov, who was born in
Sofia, Bulgaria.
He is the recipient of the 2011
Stanley Kunitz Prize from
the American Poetry Review.
He is the founder of Wild Boys,
a queer poetry salon in
New York City, works at the
Academy of American Poets,
teaches creative writing at
Rutgers University, and
frequently writes for "Poets
& Writers Magazine."
Dimitrov is the author of
"American Boys," an e-chapbook
from "Floating Wolf Quarterly."
And his new book,
"Begging For It," is just
out from Four Way Books.
He received his MFA in poetry
from Sarah Lawrence College,
and he lives in Manhattan.
Please welcome Alex Dimitrov.
ALEX DIMITROV: Hi.
So I'm going to read
some poems.
I'm thinking maybe
three or four.
And my writing prompt actually
is on a piece of paper.
It's questions, so I guess
I'll read them, but
I'll pass it down.
Is everyone excited that
it's Valentine's Day?
Yes?
How you feel about
Valentine's Day?
I have complicated feelings
about that.
OK.
This first poem is called, "This
Is a Personal Poem."
My self's self is thinking about
itself, trying to sell
itself a new self.
Don't worry, reader,
I'm not trying to
fool you with language.
I have eyes to do that with.
I have forgotten our history.
I have forgotten how we met.
Reader, are you upset at
how fast we're moving?
I'm likely with you in your
bed, between your hands,
somewhere in your mouth,
before whatever it
is you'll say next.
Say yes, and now, and love to.
Say, what did Judith Butler say
when saying, one is undone
in the face of the other, by
the touch, by the scent, by
the feel, by the prospect
of the touch, by the
memory of the feel.
I want to know you, reader.
I want to know a
lot of things.
Can we ever truly forget
about ourselves?
Is every self a self that makes
itself available to
love, like death, and its
kind availability?
Like language, reader.
Would we still be so unhappy
if we could escape it?
To name the namelessness that
is love in what we read and
what we see, and what are
feelings, really?
Facts or flaws?
For something tells me now that
I must leave you, reader.
It's not you, it's me.
We guess at why things end.
We ruin things.
We start and stall, and all,
all, all we do is want.
So it's kind of a poem about
love, but not really.
I was thinking what love poems
to read from this book,
because it's all love
poems, actually.
They're just very different
love poems.
Some are to my father, some are
to people that I've been
with, some are to women
that I love.
How about--
this one's called "Uncomplicated
Happiness."
Maybe I don't want uncomplicated
happiness.
In the morning, one of us turns
to dress away from the
other, although little
has changed.
In a better world, memory
would always
lead back to affection.
Who is that person on the edge
of the bed looking back?
Nothing is uncomplicated,
traveler.
Maybe I wanted you to stay
for the wrong reasons.
Maybe it's the wrong
reasons I love.
I, too, am somewhere over an
ocean, writing you this as
fast as I can.
Now I'll read one
that's kind of--
I don't know, really
about love, or
apparently about love.
"Sensualism." Sensualism
is not a word.
It's a word that Susan
Sontag used in one
of her journal entries.
And I loved its use,
and I love her.
So this poem's kind of thinking
about that word, and
what it is, and a lot
of other stuff.
While lying in bed, I think
about sensualism.
A mosquito presses into my
skin with such cruelty I
mistake it for love.
The stranger above my window
decides to jump, and doesn't.
Where was I?
I was opening the door to
your life and mine.
We have some words for each
other, and then what?
We have some nights in a city
next to an ocean filled with
more longing than
we can describe.
I want to place your hand
close to the knife
and let it sit there.
I want more than the cut or how
it will gently spill out.
The mosquito will drink for as
long as I'll let it, and I do.
I hold still waiting for you.
The vein rises.
It is this flood of
living that comes.
I'll read one more, and then
I'll do the prompt.
This one's called "The
Composer's Lover."
We had an hour without music, a
nerve brightly turning in a
closed room of the mind, the
heart's black pool, a word
that expired into the air
and woke everything.
Your bed slid under an
invisible knife.
What happened to us after
meeting, when the right note
claimed Manhattan's May morning
like an elegy already
moving through the living?
Today, we are among them, here
to unsettle each other, to
undress beside the piano,
elegant and unmistakably his.
Once it has you, there is a
mouth that never releases, a
faint circle in a field of
rust hanging on the wall.
We are not there.
We are in our bodies.
Like teeth marks in a shirt you
once saw falling off him,
the delicate taste of blood that
passed between us before
lust, before anyone
could forgive us.
So I did this project over the
summer called Portraits of 13
People I Don't Know
From the Internet.
And what it was was this
questionnaire that I posted on
my Tumblr, and people could come
and, if they wanted to
engage with it, they could
answer the questions, but they
had to email me back.
So I sort of tailored it to be
more about love, since it's
Valentine's Day.
So I'm going to just pass
this out [INAUDIBLE].
So it's nine questions
and one command.
This is called Love Poem, Nine
Questions, One Command.
So I'll just read
the questions.
And I also put my email on
there, if you guys want to
email me your responses,
if you feel like it.
So it's called Love Poem.
What was the happiest
time in your life?
Do you think you'll
ever be happier?
What wouldn't you do for love?
What do you want most
while you're here?
What do you want that a
poem can't give you?
What is the dish you always
order at your favorite
restaurant?
Do you have a sweater that
hugs you just right?
Who is the first person you
thought of this morning?
Who is the last person
you thought of
before bed last night?
And the command is, write
a ten line love poem of
questions like this one for
one of those people.
So if you guys feel like
it, you can do it.
And if you feel like it, you
can also send it to me.
So thank you.
Thanks for listening.
VICTORIA MCCOY: Our next reader
will be Paul Lisicky,
who's the author of "Lawn Boy,"
"Famous Builder," "The
Burning House," and most
recently, "Unbuilt Projects,"
from Four Way Books.
A graduate of the Iowa Writers
Workshop, he's the recipient
of awards from the National
Endowment for the Arts, the
James Michener Copernicus
Society, and the Fine Arts
Work Center in Provincetown.
He's currently the New Voices
professor in the MFA program
at Rutgers Camden.
Please welcome Paul Lisicky.
PAUL LISICKY: Hi, everyone.
It's lovely to be here,
and I'm excited
about reading for you.
I'm going to read some pieces
that I don't usually
read from this book.
What's happened in the past few
months since this book has
been out is that I get notes
from people who identify the
pieces that--
the favorites seem to be the
pieces that I don't pick.
So this is for all the people
who like pieces that I have
neglected, I think.
So the first is called "The
Physics of the Known World."
It's very short.
This book has a foot in poetry,
it has a foot in
fiction, and it has a foot
in the lyric essay.
It really wants to live in the
cracks between genres.
So this one is rather short.
It's all of a paragraph, and I
think of it as a theory of
love-- one of my theories
of love.
"The Physics of the
Known World."
That silly retriever.
He doesn't go to the two guys
looking right at him, beaming
him awake with concentrated
joy.
Not at all.
He goes straight to the man with
his head turned to the
left who could care less about
doggie behavior, and isn't the
least bit stirred by the snout
parked in the knee and the
wagging hind parts.
And that's it--
the physics of the known world,
which is why the trees
look better when they're
left unwatered.
And the birds actually prefer
it when you don't
sing back to them.
And the holy man crossing
the street with the
black brimmed hat?
He knows better than to pick up
what he's dropped and lift
his face to the mountains.
Take it from him, friend.
You probably wouldn't even want
it if the light hit you
in your head.
The next piece is
a bit longer--
a bit of a narrative.
This is about a life and death
experience I had with my ex.
And my ex wrote a version of
this-- a very well known poem
in which I appeared.
And I happened to be in an
audience with him next to the
poet Brenda Hillman, who turned
to me halfway through
the reading and said,
Paul, you write
your version of that.
So this is my version of Mark's
version of this story,
and it's called "In the
Unlikely Event."
I don't know why I
never read this.
There's something to be
unpacked in that.
When I watched her teaching us
the fundamentals of emergency
crash position, I thought,
this woman likes
her movies too much.
How else to account
for the way she
smiled through her tears?
Why turn her back on us
and sob into her fist?
I looked over my shoulder.
Were we sure this wasn't
being filmed?
Allen Funt.
Where on the plane
was Allen Funt?
Nevertheless, I behaved as
I was supposed to behave.
I tried not to fuss.
I tried not to make too much of
the coiffed businesswoman
to our left, who reached into
the seat pocket in front of
her, and with refinement and
discretion, put her air
sickness bag to good use.
Surely we'd laugh and clap and
laugh at the whole damn thing.
And it was only when Mark took
my hand the way others around
us took their neighbors' hands
that I felt the surge of
heartbreak, adrenaline, and
embarrassment that lets us
know we're not asleep.
How, then, in the time that
followed, did I become someone
I didn't know?
It wasn't wisdom.
I had as much wisdom in my head
as there were pain pills
in my back pocket,
which meant none.
And it certainly wasn't cool.
Even strapped in my seat and
chastened, I felt my left hand
tapping out a warning code.
Maybe some of it had to do with
the years I wouldn't get
to live out with Mark,
the fun we'd miss,
our house, our dogs.
Who would watch over our dogs?
At least the two of us would go
down at once, if that was
any kind of comfort.
But what did comfort mean when
Mark looked so unguarded and
hurt, as if he were determined
to take it personally, and
couldn't foresee that he'd one
day get a poem out of the
experience?
And here's where another
stepped in.
I wouldn't have believed it
either, if you'd told me that
my mother leapt up from her
house in Florida like some
superhero ready to
save the day.
But there she was, standing at
her sink, running hot water
over a jar she couldn't open.
And when I thought of her
getting that phone call the
next morning, just
as she wrenched
off the lid, I numbed.
Not because she loved me better
than anyone, or because
I remotely approximated the son
she'd wanted me to be, but
because she'd had enough for one
life, and the thought of
making her suffer--
guilt--
even in my last minutes above
Earth, was not something I
could take on right now.
So my two legs pushed into the
floor as if it were possible
to pilot the plane myself, even
as the damn thing wobbled
and swung and the silos
of the Midwest
looked nearer and nearer.
That's when I went through
the window.
The tiny square window
to my right.
Pinned to my seat, squeezing
Mark's hand, I thought myself
into that sky, taking myself out
of the body that was sure
to be pummeled and burned.
I was aware of my ability to
influence and not, and there
was a calm to the procedure like
what must feel like to be
an addict on a good day, when
you push your blood back and
forth through the works.
Was that why the treetops
beneath us were greener than
mangrove, or why I could so
readily think of each person
who mattered, and put a hand on
each forehead and each face
as if I'd always been faithful
to the god I'd prayed to as a
child, but hadn't known
that until now?
I thought some of the light into
the head of each person
on the plane--
to Mark, to the flight
attendant, even to the pilot,
who must have been doing the
best he could with the
creature that was trying and
failing to hold us aloft.
Not to mention my mother.
Maybe that's why we landed as
smoothly as we did, or I'm
kidding myself.
Because just when it was
clear that we were
out of harm's way--
though I'm not telling
you the whole story.
I'm leaving out firemen and
ambulances and a line of
tornadoes too obscene
to talk about--
I felt something like rage as we
waited to be transported by
bus by members of the
National Guard.
Rage to be back in a body
after the high of
being out of it.
Rage to realize I'd never
outsmart death.
Though a part of me had tricked
myself into thinking
I'd passed some test.
And, I'm going to close with a
short piece called "Two Guys."
Do any of you guys remember
a discount
store called Two Guys?
It's very far from the
world of Google 2013.
I guess it was a precursor to
Target and the discount stores
we know today, and that's sort
of the figure around which
this piece revolves.
That's all you gotta
know. "Two Guys."
When you've lost what you
remembered, New Jersey became
as tired as they said it was,
and childhood sprang traps
ready to bite into the
skin of our ankles.
Will we get it back?
Maybe it's a relief that we've
left it behind, and we can
both give thanks for the this
bout of forgetfulness.
I never really missed Two Guys
as much as I missed you--
the automatic doors, the trading
stamps, the blinding
interior, monstrous
as a spaceship.
You deserve better
than nostalgia.
There's always more to give
our lives to, even if we
thought we'd landed at
the end of the world.
May the stores be better
where you are.
May you not waste a single
second thinking about what you
should or shouldn't buy.
And if you should hear a boy
calling for his mother by the
record department, walk on.
He's doing much better than
you think, really.
He owes you that.
The songs are blue and
glistening, even if he has a
hard time making sense
of them from here.
So thank you.
My prompt.
Write about an object while
you think the word goodbye
without using the word
goodbye in the piece.
I'll say it again.
Write about an object, and think
about the word goodbye
without using the word
goodbye in the piece.
And that is it.
Thanks very much.
VICTORIA MCCOY: Victoria Redel
is the author of three books
of poetry and three books of
fiction, most recently "Woman
Without Umbrella," from
Four Way Books.
Her novel "Loverboy" was awarded
the 2001 S. Mariella
Gable Novel Award, and the 2002
Forward Silver Literary
Fiction Prize, chosen in 2001 as
a "Los Angeles Times" Best
Book, and adapted for
a feature film
directed by Kevin Bacon.
Redel is a professor at Sarah
Lawrence College, and has
received fellowships from the
National Endowment For the
Arts, and the Fine
Arts Work Center.
Please welcome Victoria Redel.
VICTORIA REDEL: I feel
like I should be
running a board meeting.
That's what I was thinking.
Like Alex, I feel like most of
my book is some version of a
love poem or the end of love,
so I'm going to read four
poems, and this first one is
a poem called "Upgrade."
I don't want to say it didn't
fit, never worked, or worked
at first, then in fits and
starts, the switches useless,
gears stripped.
No, I don't want customer
service, a claims department,
complaint letters, an exchange
or credit towards the latest
model, an upgrade, or lifetime
parts replacement.
Even now, broken, chipped, in
pieces, pieces lost, worn out,
the original gone, there
are times still it
comes back to me whole.
And I am amazed by what is
beyond fragile, by how
elaborately and generously
wrecked and beyond repair we
made use of our hearts all
those years, and then.
So this poem sort of, I guess,
in a certain way, is a
Valentine, this next one.
I think of a Valentine as being
some kind of direct
address to someone, you know?
Some little heart you're giving,
in some version of it.
"Today We're This World's
Darling."
All the trees on Broadway
thrill white petals--
different time of year
than Valentine's Day.
All the trees on Broadway
thrill white petals.
Daffodils gather in bouquets to
fling themselves at us like
schoolgirls.
Shopkeepers lean from doors, tip
hats, toss candy and fish.
Sidewalks sparkle up
to catch our eye.
Holy moly, even the incorrigible
past has arrived,
pledging it will finally learn
goodness and mercy.
Don't look up.
Don't wave back or wink.
Hurry off the avenue
and bolt the door.
By tomorrow, snickering,
showoff, fake, they'll croon
for Lindsay, or Nick's black
eye, the publicist of
someone's rehabbed
heart rumors.
Maples will turn gold
for his comeback.
Ovid can tell you, give it 15
minutes, and if you're lucky,
you're banished to an island.
Or like Poe, your obit written
by the enemy Griswold declares
in print, few will grieve.
There's Bessie Smith in
her unmarked grave.
Let biographers flock to the
clever and pretty, declare us
old, drab, utterly
last season.
And when they're gone, chasing
the next fabulous story, say
again just one of those things
I can't repeat here--
those gorgeous, scandalous,
tender words you say to me
each morning that would make
them quiver that would change
their lives.
So this next one I'm going to
read I've only ever read out
loud once before, and it's a
poem called "Kissing." And how
I came to write it was that I
had received an invitation to
be part of an anthology which
was an anthology called "Dirty
Words," and each of the writers
could choose a dirty
word and write a piece
about it-- a
poem, a story, an essay.
Whatever they wanted.
I received my list of dirty
words, and they were really
pretty dirty words.
And I kind of looked at
it, and I thought,
oh, I'll choose later.
And I freaked out and put it
away, and then didn't deal
with it for a while.
And then they came back and they
said, well, it's great.
Everyone's chosen words.
There are two words left.
And one word was condom,
and the other
word was a dirty Pierre.
I didn't know what
dirty Pierre was.
Oh, look, someone
knew what it--
I had no clue what it was, so
I thought, well, I'm really
out of this anthology.
But I looked and looked at the
list, and I realized that the
word kissing wasn't on the
list of dirty words.
So I decided to try to write a
poem called "Kissing," and try
to look at it as seriously
as I could.
"Kissing."
The first surprise of your mouth
and mine, on streets, on
staircases, in bathrooms, in the
backs of cabs, in a field
against that wall and that
wall and that wall.
Down on the floor, my hair
caught in it, in hotel beds,
in a borrowed bed, and in the
same bed, night after night
after year after night, through
an open window, under
pines, underwater, on a raft,
in rain, salty with ocean, a
peck at the door, a
have a good day.
Our mouths, prepositional.
Eyes open, eyes closed, your
face in transport.
Combustible.
At the sink doing dishes, and
suddenly you're turning me,
saying, give me your mouth, and
I'm giving you my mouth,
coming up out of it stunned,
like there is another room
inside, and then another room.
Strawberries, sourness of
coffee, a slight fizzy
sweetness of a clean grass taste
as only you taste, your
face so close to mine.
A fluency accented, each vowel
and consonant exactly formed.
Sudden native speakers.
Morning just wakened, still slow
and thick and dreaming,
turning away from your reach.
Kissing like nobody's business,
like something
windy, like good weather.
In winter, our mouths the
warmest place in the city.
A lower lip flecked by teeth
pulling back just a little to
breathe together.
Snuck, stolen, last, first,
unbidden, forbidden, sloppy,
delicious, French, farewell,
slippery, criminal.
A private syntax.
Pun and slang, slip of
tongue, intentional.
Could I have known on the
Harwood building's stairwell
with my first fast dry
12-year-old kiss that I'd
become a woman who'd drive
across state lines for the
moment just before
the kiss begins?
What I miss is the makeout.
That's what I go for if I had
an night on the lam, the
married woman says, looking at
a couple who have rolled off
their picnic blanket.
One of us might say, only this,
and then it's the first
night all over again, tumble and
wrestle, every mystical,
dirty, delicious thing
two mouths manage.
Kiss me goodbye, you say, and
on a street among strangers
and floppy hats and winter
coats, we slip into one
another to say last apologies
and promises.
In a bank line, or sitting
at a table with
friends, I touch my mouth.
I am drifting, or you are
drifting, and one pressed
against the other whispers,
good night.
The last one.
The day's punctuation.
This is the last one.
"And Then."
What if, darling, tonight we
tell only the best stories we
have of other loves?
Not just nights of pleasure,
but the way he laughed from
the back of his throat, the
truthful things she said that
made you cry.
What about that spring wind, and
when there was a bicycle,
a downpour, and someone had
or didn't have a poncho?
Someone said the very thing
you longed to hear.
You told a secret,
and were safe.
She had a fever.
He lost a father.
There were good meals.
To think of those fine shoes we
scuffed about in, thinking
we were royalty.
And remember that plastic tiara,
and the clumsy pavan?
Remember what you wished,
and how he wished, too?
Look at us now drink coffee,
talk about the day's
particulars and possibilities.
Morning light folds across
the wood table.
Could we bear to look at one
another knowing how full the
heart has already been?
How we come together as not just
thankful refugees from
sorrow, but wild too, with easy
days of mismatched socks?
This morning, we think we
couldn't be happier.
That's courage.
We thought it before.
So my prompt to you guys is
to think of objects--
socks, shoes, lights, tables,
all the things in a life.
And think of them in relation
to the sentence, when you
left, what I started
to think about was.
So, when you left, what I
started to think about was.
Thanks.
VICTORIA MCCOY: Our final reader
today will be Jonathan
Wells, whose poems have appeared
in "The New Yorker,"
"Poetry International,"
"Hayden's Ferry," and other
publications.
He's the author of "Train Dance"
from Four Way Books,
and edited "Third Rail, The
Poetry of Rock and Roll" from
MTV Books, which was
published in 2007.
He lives and works
in New York City.
Please welcome Jonathan Wells.
JONATHAN WELLS: Hello.
Thanks for coming.
I'm going to read a couple of
poems from "Train Dance,"
although I didn't really think
of it as a book of love poems
in any conventional or
unconventional sense.
So I may have to read a couple
which aren't in the book, just
because that's what the
situation demands.
This is called "London
Plane," and it's
not a plane to London.
It's a tree, which will
become very clear.
"London Plane."
When I'm alone, the tree I love
whispers and calls to me,
indifferent to the season.
I come to her in spring, when
she's in bud, and winter when
she's naked, only
one side warm.
In fall, she forgets
herself and dreams.
I come to her for learning and
read her bark like Braille.
Her arms are twisted, lifted for
attention, glassed in rain
or wrapped in mist, or grey.
She speaks from her own
wisdom, not always
prompted by the wind.
I come without ideas of love,
for she is already rough and
rounded, cankered, tall,
and we are not alone.
Finches listen from her
branches, and plastic bags
luff, confiding my desires
in the wind.
The tree I love lowers me
from my window ledge,
equal to her height.
She says, sit close to me.
When I call to you, what
loneliness makes you listen?
The next poem is "Untitled,"
which is its title.
You taught me the river, its
slender hands, fugitive smile,
and phosphorescence.
The river became my
blood, my voice.
Some mornings, when the earth
smells of earthworms and mist,
a guitar will steal the river's
chords from the
underneath of leaves.
A violin will take its
deeper wood, the cat
gut strings its notes.
We walk the river, rock to
rock, the river's shape a
fossil snake and a million
miles of rock.
The ears, the mouth, the neck,
the bitten palm of rock.
Watch it go.
Oh, never let me go.
As you'll see from my prompt,
I think I specialize in
indirectness.
And so this is a poem called
"Squirrel Watching."
The leash is taut, her doleful
eyes transfixed as she lifts
her snout to heaven, every
imaginable taste
almost in her mouth.
Tickling tail boa, crunchy
bones, and haunch.
The squirrel freezes his body
spread eagled on the bark,
terrified alert, condescending
to a love that smells so much
like blood.
Each feature is profound.
Wide black eyes stunned open,
many paws circling a nut in a
blur, a dash of rust splashed on
his back, peaky ears, and a
white throat scarf.
Her love is the devouring
of the whole in parts.
She waits, measuring his speed
against her strike, and leaps,
believing it was true.
But if it were, the world would
be bare of squirrels
that looked away.
And my poems are short.
I guess I've got time
for one or two more.
This is called "The Second
Book of Love."
He read aloud to her from "The
Second Book of Love," and all
the other books.
She listened without listening,
as if it were a
mist that drifted through her.
He read, not noticing
she slept.
He didn't know these words would
one day shape his lips.
The old feelings would slip
away and disappear.
The trees would shine in an
amber light that the once
fresh light had turned into.
Some pages would be as bright
as sun spots on the surface.
Others would be torn or torched
under a magnifying
glass without remorse.
Crossed out words could
still be glimpsed.
It was a work still circling,
a story that lay open on the
lectern of crowded rooms and
distracted nights, written by
two unlinked hands.
It was made from the five
senses, and the sense of
hovering above the air.
It was the book of hours,
the strip of days.
In its line was the confusion
between what was unsayable and
what can't be said.
Last poem that I'll read is--
we moved into a new district
recently, which has a lot of
shops which sell wigs.
So I always imagined
which one I'd like.
And so I actually never went
into the wig shops, and wrote
the poem instead.
"House of Wigs."
The sky was low.
His head was a vase of
sorrows he wanted
to fill with blossoms.
He stepped into the
house of wigs.
The sales lady said,
try this one on.
It's called the mind of fire.
It turns ashes into flame.
Prometheus was wearing it, they
say, when he was punished
by the gods for his
compassion.
And he barely felt the eagle's
claws landing on his stomach.
This one is known as the parable
of spring for its
rhythm and its pageant.
The fresh grass and forsythia
will carry you towards summer,
your body lithe and
unencumbered, your hunger fed
by fields of daisies.
I'm wearing love's crown, she
said, because love shouldn't
be a neon idol shining
on a shelf.
It must be worn and worn
through, and not just the love
you bring, but what you can
accept, especially when the
days are short and brooding.
Go ahead, she said.
Put it on.
Stand next to the light.
So I guess when I was trying to
think of a prompt, and what
might be helpful, I couldn't
really think about what I do,
because I don't know
what I do.
But based on what I've done, I
tried to figure out what I do.
And so what I think that would
be helpful is to think about
someone or something you love,
and think of something as
specific, as particular as you
can get about the person.
A look, an expression,
a gesture.
And don't think about
naming the emotion.
Think about the thing, and then
the emotion itself will
come through it.
And so that's not as specific a
prompt as one could get, but
that's the best I can do.
Good luck.
Thank you.